[Music]
one of the ideas behind servant is that
we never leave
the brownstone on spruce street
and that was the conceit give it this
kind of suffocating feeling
so episode one of season three where
leanne goes outside for the first time
is something i really look forward to to
directing because it it's a very
hitchcockian sequence of paranoia it's
her trying to overcome her almost
crippling anxiety about going outside
from the beginning when you see her from
behind she's gathering her strengths she
wanted this life she wanted to stay in
this brownstone but she knows that
something dark's coming for her so can
she even enjoy this anymore all she's
ever wanted to be is this normal girl in
this family
can i just take a walk down the street
we had to go through the wall and we
actually did go through the wall to kind
of come on the outside and then dip down
and then zoom in
is a much harder shot than it looks
all the sound effects explode and the
room is filling up with her paranoia
just each step with this wide-angle lens
this sense of like it's very hard to
walk just keep going and her forcing
herself to go forward
leanne keeps looking around over her
shoulder to see if anybody's going to
run up behind her and attack her and
we're doing very close shots so you can
see her face is warping with with how
wide our lens is and it's like kept
getting closer to her closer to her
because she's feeling suffocated even
though she's outside
there's this stranger that looks awfully
like uncle george the person that
attacked her in season two
and she's watching him and going why is
he standing there
meanwhile julian's trying to break up
with her over her shoulder
she's sick of being
told what to do she finds her strength
here this is what this frame is the
walking stops and now she's gonna go and
be a different person and now it's time
i think no
she feels foolish and she's like i can't
be normal out here and so she grabs the
baby and she's very upset
julian's outside and then you see
boom
[Music]
the house starting to fall apart the
house and her are kind of tied and as
she gets angry and feels certain
emotions the house manifests that
i found this episode so scary and
unnerving
and leans into the things that i'm
passionate about
which is paranoia and suspense and like
kind of that wink as we kind of tumble
into darker and darker things for leanne
[Music]
you